[Music]
and chess.com is here with the 2019 u.s
champion now the five-time winner grand
master of cara nakamura first of all
congratulations
thank you mike it's phil's good to win
again but for much of my career much my
life
i've sort of been the bad guy very often
times i've always been perceived as the
person
who people don't want to root for who
people don't like
the car was like oh that guy has more
money than me he gets more viewers so
i'm gonna try to get in on that because
he only cares if the people he's
supporting act
the exact way he wants check me good
game
particularly quick karu drastic measures
to halt the spread of that deadly virus
wuhan china ground zero for the outbreak
now under lockdown
that dude is really funny really
entertaining he networks with people i
think you could get literally any game
to go big on twitch if you have the
right name behind it i think something
like totally agree
ah checkmate enjoy the elo lost
[ __ ] oh my gosh oh my gosh i
sucked out oh i'm so terrible at chess i
can also trade and take and take and it
takes i
take it takes takes takes queen e2 queen
h4 g3 knight g3
check c6 queen b7 knight h1 king there
i don't know what's going on i'm just
going to castle i don't want to think
too much
everything i do i don't do it lightly
there's no time for fun and games you
have to like
make the most of your life no matter
what it is or else or else you're uh
you're wasting your life
hikaru nakamura is a man of many
accomplishments
he drew the chess world's attention to
the united states by winning trophy
after trophy throughout his career
and chess.com is here with the 2019 u.s
champion now the five-time winner grand
master hikaru nakamura first of all
congratulations
thank you mike it's phil's good to win
again in 2003
he became a record-breaking grand master
nakamura is now 27 and he became the
youngest grand master
in american history when he was just 15.
bobby fischer had held the record for
nearly half a century
he plays one of the most challenging
games in the world
at breakneck speeds i can also trade and
take and take and it takes i
take it takes takes takes queenie two
queen h4 g3 knight g3
check c6 queen b7 knight h1 king there
i don't know what's going on i'm just
gonna castle i don't wanna think too
much and most recently hakar breathed
new life
into a game that has existed for nearly
1500 years
by playing chess with some of the
biggest streamers on the planet
best move would be the with my [ __ ] up
right e3
it's a move
[Music]
oh draw what the heck all right
does that count as a win or do i have to
beat you again okay now actually what
happens here is i have checkmated one
um so i play this rook takes this
actually check me
because you see my bishop protects this
knight and your king can't go anywhere
here
but before any of that happened hikaru's
mother made the fateful decision to move
from japan
to the united states along with her two
children hikaru's older brother asaka
was the first of the two boys to take an
interest in chess
helped along by the influence of their
stepfather fide master
sunil wimamatri then then i started
dating his mom and
he got who didn't play chess i mean he
was he was a pain in the neck at that
time
and it was like you know i mean oscar
was successful
after asuka began competing nationally
the family often traveled across the
country to attend events
and it wasn't long before the
six-year-old hikaru
found himself eager to get off the
sidelines and compete
i didn't want him at first to play chess
because i thought it was unfair
to have him measure up to his brother
who was very good
right you know i thought that was
putting too much of a burden so i tried
to but the more i pushed him away
the more interested he began and hekar's
determination to test himself against
others even at the age of seven led him
to winning his first tournament ever
by the time he turned nine his parents
made the decision to homeschool him so
that he could focus on improving at
chess
and when he was 10 hikaru overtook his
brother earning the title of chess
master but the real turning point came
when at 15 years and 79 days
hikaru broke bobby fisher's 1958 record
to become the youngest american grand
master ever
as a player hakaru quickly became known
for his aggressive play style
bullet unpredictable weird
i would say as a player for me sharp
wild aggressive tricky he spent
countless hours playing chess online but
as he told tanya sachdev in 2017
eventually he found out that it was more
important to study your opponent's
strategies at the highest levels of the
game
when you start out it depends what you
can get away with what you can't get
away with and kind of learning
you know figuring out how to how to
understand what works and what doesn't
and when you play against the best
players in the world i mean
you can try certain things but you have
to be
much more practical and i think that's
that's it's a natural evolution it's how
things evolve
for for all the top players i think
still his foray into the world of online
chess
showed hikaru a way to bring more new
players into the fold
if someone was good enough playing
online gave them a way to test their
skills against grand masters and
learn from the experience again i'm
starting at 500 which also means the
people who are near the bottom of this
will have the chance to play against but
usually when i do the viewer speed runs
on my main accounts i end up playing
only people who are 2000 or better
so this gives everyone a great great
opportunity in the meantime
hikaru continued to climb the ranks of
competitive chess
he represented the united states at five
chess olympiads winning a gold medal
and two team bronzes as well as picking
up a number of
other prestigious chess trophies along
the way hikaru
excelled at one style of play in
particular
blitz chess three to five minute matches
that unlike classical chess
allow players mere seconds to make their
move yes
hey i think it's yeah check and check
and check me yeah there we go being the
world's greatest player in what is
arguably the most entertaining type of
chess to watch made hakaru the face of
the game for many casual fans
i think any game however boring no
offense i love chess okay however boring
the game is which chess
is if you have the right person behind
it you can sell anything and the icaru
guy or whatever hikaru garu i don't know
like that dude is really funny really
entertaining he networks with people
i think you could get literally any game
to go big on twitch if you had the right
name behind it i think somebody like
totally agree
hikaru was out to show people that chess
was more than just an
ancient board game for the elite and
what came next
helped him do just that in a way that
not even a chess grain master could have
predicted
[Music]
the mystery virus started here in the
city of
wuhan measures to halt the spread of
that deadly virus
wuhan china ground zero for the outbreak
now under lockdown a city of 11 million
now halting all public transportation
and outbound flight
we will immediately close all shops
selling non-essential goods will stop
all gatherings of more than two people
in public that both canada and the
united states will temporarily restrict
all non-essential travel across the
canada-us border
the global pandemic that put life on
hold for just about everyone
also put a stop to all real-life chess
tournaments but
hakaru needed an outlet to compete and
so
he decided to turn his occasional twitch
streams into a full-time pursuit
i should um so some of the side things
came out you see they came out i should
put the replacements in
i should like tape it together and sell
it i should sell it for uh 200 000
that's actually what i should do because
i mean it's it's a mouse i mean a mouse
is more durable it has more quality than
a banana so why can't i sell this mouse
for 200 000
right what accaro didn't realize at the
time was that he was about to change the
way people thought about chess
forever unlike many other notable
players out there makaru was
approachable he first began streaming
part-time in 2017 and came to understand
quickly how best to keep his audience
engaged he interacted with his chat
and tried to make his streams both
educational and fun
by late 2019 about 2 000 people would
tune in to watch akaru play
but as more time passed that number
jumped to about 20
000 viewers with the chess category on
twitch growing
six-fold by the time summer rolled
around the game had become so
popular that chess.com partnered with
twitch to bring its viewers pog champs
a chess tournament featuring several
notable streamers with akaru providing
commentary for the event
i win though right i win i win
[Music]
the issue i have with that is that he
gave up the night
and the only reason you should give up
the night is if you're 100
sure you know how to make the checkmate
the choice of commentator
seemed obvious hikaru's on-stream antics
like playing blindfolded or doing chess
challenge runs had encouraged some of
twitch's biggest stars to give the game
a try
and no matter what his opponent's skill
level was hikaru
always made sure they walked away
feeling like they learned something
just do some puzzles just play a little
bit and um
and and you'll you'll you'll you won't
lose in six moves i can assure you that
much
that's big
thank you for the kind words of telling
me i won't lose in six turns that's
actually very nice i mean no problem and
like i i think like
closer to the event when there's time if
like if you if you want to if you want
to do another lesson just let me know
and we
can we can do more and takara learned
something too that it was possible to
take a traditionally dry and
serious game like chess and combine it
with the ridiculousness of twitch
culture
oh my gosh oh my gosh i sucked out
oh i'm so terrible at chess nikara's
unique offering as a content creator
couldn't be denied and in august of 2020
tsm swooped in
adding him to their roster of streaming
talent but not
everyone saw hikaru's willingness to be
twitch's chess ambassador
as a good thing some thought he was
compromising the integrity of the game
by playing with amateurs simply to
bolster his channel's popularity
so obviously if you're a normal person
who has talent
like magnus carlsen or you know
mvl kramnik you know you ignore people
with no talent but
hicaro's like oh that guy has more money
than me he gets more viewers so
i'm gonna try to get in on that and
there were other chess streamers who
felt like
sometimes he was trying to be king of
the board when hikaro was doing
commentary
on his channel for stuff we were told to
not do our commentary at the same time
three days before the event was
finishing and we were planning ours that
we were gonna host we said
oh we totally forgot about something but
a hundred percent we need to make it on
hikaru's channel and i said you know
that feels a bit disingenuous and that
is when they cut off contact with us and
said oh well now you're calling us liars
so actually we're going to do the event
entirely by ourselves
so it's just it's fake
still chess was hikaru's life he
dedicated himself to it completely
having never even
had a job outside of playing the game
and he was determined to bring his
passion into the masses that embraced
him no matter what anyone had to say
but for much of my career much of my
life i've sort of been the bad guy not
someone who has been liked very
very often times i've always been
perceived as the person
who people don't want to root for who
people don't like
and and so to have all the support from
you guys um
you know to sort of know there are fans
who do support me
um it does mean a lot and that that's
that's kind of the biggest difference
for me
with now versus much of my chess career
not that hikaru was a stranger to tense
standoffs
his well-publicized rivalry with fellow
gm and
current world champion magnus carlson
has been gossip fodder in the chess
world for
[Music]
years
[Music]
[Laughter]
at the end of the day though there were
no real hard feelings between the two
and and the reason that i have the
issues with magnus or at least i've had
the issues in these online events
very specifically is because magnus is
slightly better at defending
slightly better pressing end game so
this is very slight margin when you're
playing at someone
who's slightly who does these things i
mean i wouldn't even say there's a big
difference but he does all these little
things slightly better
that's when you kind of have to start
mixing up with the style and playing
differently
the renaissance chess experienced on
twitch thanks in no small part to hikaru
ended up bringing the game of chess
back into the mainstream and with the
success of shows like netflix's the
queen's gambit
it doesn't look like it's returning to
obscurity any time soon can you imagine
magnus playing it's like good game dude
here's a hug like
yeah that would never that would never
happen um
of course now that i say that now that i
say that
probably for the meme something weird
like that will happen it's hard to deny
that
hikaru nakamura is the instrumental
force behind the world's renewed
interest in chess and for him the
continued popularity of chess on twitch
and beyond
means only one thing hikaru can continue
to keep his opponents in check
for a long time to come to have all you
guys watching all the things that i've
done over the last year and half two
years like
it's not something where like you know
i'm just doing whatever and random and
blah blah blah like you have to work
very hard to be successful and i feel
like
acting like these people are just like
doing doing nothing like i mean it just
it just it's just showing a lack of
understanding of how twitch
how the internet how youtube how all
these platforms work
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages